good morning Hank it's Tuesday as you
can tell from the great speckled walls
behind me I am in an airport and as you
can tell from my cold dead eyes it's 542
in the morning also I forgot my
camcorder so I'm filming this on my
phone I have a bunch of things to tell
you but I also want to give you some
travel tips so I'm gonna intersperse
them thing one Hank the Paper Towns
movie they moved the release date it is
now coming out on July 24th that is the
real date it will really come out on
that day I think that's very good news
because it means that Jake and everybody
will have time to actually finish the
movie also there is going to be a
trailer soon how soon I can't tell you
but pretty pretty soon ok travel tip in
almost every airport in the United
States there is a gate that is empty all
the time in our case in Indianapolis its
gate a 3 this is where I come to make
video blogs because there are no people
here if you're at an airport take the
time to walk around and find the empty
gate because there are plugs and chairs
and freedom sadly that travel tip does
not apply to people in Los Angeles New
York Chicago or Atlanta thing too the
Looking for Alaska movie so like my
first book Looking for Alaska came out
10 years ago and the movie rights have
been owned ever since by Paramount but
suddenly it seems like a Looking for
Alaska movie might actually happen
because the team has gotten back
together the same screenwriters who
wrote The Fault in Our Stars and Paper
Towns Scott Neustadter and Mike Weber
are going to be writing the script and
the producers have both Fault in Our
Stars and Paper Towns have joined in as
well so and that is very exciting travel
tips oh this is the fancy airport lounge
don't pay to go to the airport lounge
it's never worth it you think there's
gonna be like milk and honey and beds in
there you know what they have I'll tell
you exactly what's in there alcohol and
cookies that's it that's what you will
find in the airport lounge so unless you
really love to drink or are cookie
monster there is no way that it's worth
it if you want to go to a quiet private
place in the airport don't go to the
lounge go to the chapel
almost every airport has a chapel and
they are always nice and pleasant and
very quiet places make I notice most of
my travel tips are like how do you get
away from other travelers Hank the
biggest movie news of all is that I have
seen the Paper Towns movie and it is
great I'm just so psyched about it and
so grateful to everyone who's working on
it Hank it's one thing to be faithful to
a books plot it's another to be faithful
to the themes of a book and I really
feel like the Paper Towns movie is about
learning to imagine others complexes I'm
just so psyched about it no spoilers but
I am psyched
it's final travel Tepeyac when walking
on the moving walkway be very careful
not to step on a crack let's do you
break your mother's back okay I have to
go bored sorry about the iPhone video
July 24th Paper Towns movie I'll see you
on Friday